[Musique]
il parlait de vous dans le journal les
une grosse part de mensonge mais
j'imagine que c'est pas très grave
je suis pas un enfant de choeur vous
êtes billy le kid
mon père a battu ma mère à mort
[Musique]
faut qu'on se fasse discret vous nous
emmenez avec vous
ça fait combien de temps que tu es
shérif de semaine là je suis vraiment
flatté
quand il commence à parler de toi tu es
un homme mort la gauche devient l'ennemi
public numéro un il ya des familles dont
ses écrits qui ont souffert des crimes
de cette homme sortait beaux-arts il
devrait en faire autant pas de moi je
profite de la vie il faut seulement boni
vient chercher romero
[Musique]
vous pensez pouvoir m'échapper
personne n'a besoin de mourir
aujourd'hui ce que c'est pas une dure
réalité de la vie
j'sais pas quoi de plus si ce sera ton
dernier
vous croyez vraiment je suis comme vous
c'est que c'est mon jour de chance
merveilleux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu crois que je ferais si
tu touches à celle de ses cheveux
j'emmène mon neveu avec moi ils vont
tous dire que tu es une poule mouillée
et que tu t'es enfui ils savent que
c'est des conneries on s'en fout que ce
soit vrai ou pas l'important c'est
l'histoire qui vont raconter une fois
que tu seras plus là
[Musique]